la méthode a été décrié outre atlantique
elle a été utilisée dans le cadre de la
crise sanitaire pour l'organisation des
élections présidentielles américaines
donald trump grand perdant du scrutin a
fini par crier à la fraude électorale
et pourtant le vote électronique
pourrait prochainement débarquer en
france
vous l'aurez peut être deviné nous
sommes au sénat qui examine en ce moment
même le projet de loi sur l'organisation
de l'élection présidentielle de 2022
et c'est dans ce contexte précis que le
gouvernement a présenté à la toute
dernière minute ce mardi un amendement
pour organiser le vote anticipé des
électeurs dans un certain nombre de
collectivités sur des machines à voter
ce vote serait une alternative au vote
par procuration est il interviendrait
dans la semaine précédant le scrutin dès
2022 si les parlementaires le décide
voici ce que dit le texte le jour du
scrutin à 19 heures le président du
bureau de vote rend visible les
compteurs totalisant les suffrages
exprimés par chaque candidat ainsi que
les votes blancs de manière à en
permettre la lecture par les membres du
bureau de vote les délégués des
candidats et les électeurs présents des
garanties seraient prévues pour éviter
un double vote les résultats ne seraient
dépouillés que le soir de l'élection
comme pour les bureaux de vote
ordinaires et garanties loin d'être
suffisante pour la majorité de droite
ici au sénat qui devrait rejeter cet
amendement
bruno retailleau chef de file des
républicains ici au palais du luxembourg
dénonce même une magouille politicienne
de la part de l'elysée
c'est un amendement qui est venu
précipitamment sans que le conseil
d'état n'ait pu examiner sa portée sans
que nous mêmes nous ayons pu faire un
travail parlementaire approfondie c'est
en catimini et ça ça évoque évidemment
des soupçons puis c'est surtout l'aspect
beaucoup plus du fond puisque
les électeurs ne seront pas en situation
d'égalité il y à des électeurs urbains
qui seront tout près des machines à
voter et d'autres qui sont très loin à
1h 2h 3h aller retour de du centre du
département et donc yann comment
dirais-je une égalité de traitement et
ça pose un sujet d'ailleurs d'ordre
constitutionnel puis un autre sujet
qu'elle la sincérité du scrutin
pourquoi parce que on voit bien que si
vous votez le mercredi et qu' il se
passe un bouleversement un événement
énorme entre le mercredi et le dimanche
de l'élection
vous avez peut-être envie de changer
votre vote mais vous ne le pourrait pas
et de plus en plus on voit bien que les
votes se cristallisent tardivement
donc là aussi un vrai problème et ce
n'est pas une méthode de toute façon
cette précipitation cache en réalité je
le pense
malheureusement une manoeuvre électorale
visant avantage est peut-être un peu
plus la participation d'un électorat
dont on suppose qu'il est plus proche de
monsieur ma crainte que d'autres
candidats voilà cet amendement doit être
soumis ce jeudi au palais du luxembourg
en séance publique le vote électronique
serait une première à l'échelle
nationale des machines à voter sont en
effet utilisés localement à
palavas-les-flots notamment mais elles
restent marginales dans le système
électoral français
d'autant que depuis 2008 un moratoire
limité leur usage aux collectivités qui
en disposent